you take your Halloween seriously I do I
love Halloween it's one of my favorite
holidays I love horror films so that's
that's my in rank yeah and and and I'm
just curious in the past like costumes
how serious have you gone like for
example what did you do last year
remember last year stranger things was
very big last year and I always find
that my costumes are super last-minute
and my girlfriend and I decided last
minute I was like I'm gonna be 11 from
stranger things so I shaved my head
mm-hmm
this is like the night before Halloween
right shaved my head and 11:00 for
anyone who doesn't know she's a girl
she's a girl who's how old 11 or 12 11
or 12 yeah yeah
I'm guessing 11 yes and yeah I went out
and got a dress went thrift shopping got
a dress died at pink um got some like
knee socks and yes I've got a got that
she's like a thing of Eggo waffles I
heard that around and then I had um the
the drip of blood coming down it knows
you brought a photo I haven't seen it
yet but I want to see this is you
great my girlfriend is a very good mic
as it turns out he's a terrific mind
yeah we really nailed it why don't you
like wearing the dress how did you did
you like it I loved it I loved it I the
closest thing I've ever experienced to
address before was wearing a kilt but
it's just that freedom you know there's
nothing getting what I felt like just be
who you really are
now I thought I thought the same thing I
wore a kilt at a wedding I ever worn a
kilt and I never it is fantastic it's
great it's hard to explain but it's just
it's like yeah I get this it's fantastic
yeah three yeah everything's flapping
around it's fantastic great did you go
with sands underwear which is the
traditional way to do it I I think I had
no underwear and then I was told to put
underwear on maybe were you're not aware
of how you were sitting I was aware of
I'm a big creep
yep going and down up and down some
circular stairs yeah for like I was at
the Apple store that had that glass pour
I'm looking for the new iPhone
you